warnung an die spd nach der
mitgliederentscheid fordert die union
die große koalition nicht zu gefährden
hoffnung auf veränderung katholiken in
deutschland wollen tiefgreifende
reformen der kirche anstoßen traum
comeback in kanada thomas dreesen siegt
beim abfahrts weltcup nach einjähriger
verletzungspause
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster und damit herzlich
willkommen bei den heute -nachrichten am
ersten advent natürlich auch mit sport
und norbert könig kuno winn
die entscheidung der spd basis für ihr
neues spitzenduo hat viele verblüfft und
sorgt parteiübergreifend für nervosität
gelten saskia esken und norbert walter
borjans doch als coco skeptiker die den
fortbestand der regierung an bedingungen
knüpfen
so wollen beide einen höheren
mindestlohn und mehr investitionen in
der koalition durchsetzen
auf kosten der schwarzen null thomas
reichert am tag nach dem politischen
beben versuchen alle erst mal so zu tun
als sei es gerade kein beben
sie sei froh dass die spd sich
entschieden habe ob man nun zur sache
weil zurückkehren könne
lässt die cdu-vorsitzende wissen die cdu
ist ganz klar wir stehen zu dieser
koalition
wir stehen zu dieser koalition auf der
grundlage die verhandelt ist und wir
wollen uns schnell der sacharbeit widmen
zurück zur sacharbeit zum bestehenden
koalitionsvertrag aber wollen die
designierten neuen parteichefs gerade
nicht bei der balance und essen haben
neue forderungen beim mindestlohn
grundrente und klima das nicht zu machen
dass wenn es der blockade haltungen gibt
dann ist das ein grund warum eben auch
einen parteitag sich gedanken darüber
machen wird wie man mit diesen mit
diesen differenzen auch umgeht aber der
inhalt steht im vordergrund und an dem
entscheidet sich ob diese koalition
bestand hat doch das unterlegene scholz
lager würde gerade das gerne verhindern
nach dieser klaren vereinbarung das ist
um eine personalentscheidung an der
spitze der spd geht geht es eben nicht
in erster linie und sich automatisch um
eine neuausrichtung der gesamten spd
politik und auch die gewerkschaften
drängen die spd zum weitermachen in der
großen koalition
dieses land hat erheblichen
modernisierungsbedarf dafür brauchen wir
ein anspruchsvolles
zukunftsinvestitionsprogramm das sind
themen die muss die regierung in der
zweiten spielzeit der regierungsperiode
in angriff nehmen die chancen darauf
habe sind deutlich gesunken
am nächsten wochenende wollen die
künftigen spd chefs auf einem parteitag
klären an welchen ihrer forderungen das
überleben der groko hängt auch in
sachsen regierte bislang eine große
koalition doch dafür reicht es nach der
landtagswahl vor knapp drei monaten
nicht mehr
jetzt die einigung auf ein neues bündnis
die sogenannte kenia koalition
die spitzen von cdu grünen und spd
stellten heute in dresden den
koalitionsvertrag vor
damit kann ministerpräsident kretschmann
wohl weiter regieren
allerdings muss bei der cdu noch ein
parteitag zustimmen spd und grüne wollen
ihre basis befragen seit vier monaten
steht ursula von der leyen in den
startlöchern heute fiel der startschuss
als neue präsidentin der eu kommission
hat sie angekündigt auf allen feldern
neue akzente zu setzen
doch es sind schwierige zeiten für
europa das parlament zersplittert wie
nie und die staaten oft zerstritten
gunnar gründe das also soll der frische
start sein
das versprechen von ursula von der leyen
amtsantritt bei drei grad eher ein
zufall des kalenders führt die spitzen
der eu in ihrem museum
es würde gerade zehn jahre
lissabon-vertrag quasi europas
grundgesetz wir haben die verantwortung
in europa zu hinterlassen das stärker
ist als das das wir geerbt haben ein
blick in den umzug gibt es auf twitter
wo die neue chefin verrät es sei nun
zeit sich zu bewegen die inszenierung
ist dynamisch die aufgabe enorm
die neue kommission will einen green
deal fürs klima will die digitalisierung
verträglich gestalten und nebenbei die
verteilung von flüchtlingen neu regeln
im museum erhält von der leyen eine
kopie von lissabon vertrag den sie nun
hüten soll
der vertrag erlaubt entscheidung per
mehrheit in der praxis aber braucht sie
für ihre projekte die zustimmung aller
listen als wir sollten uns beim vertrag
inspirieren lassen und die positiven
reformen in den alltag der bürger
übertragen sie erwarten vielfach sexy
tour neue botschaft der kommission mehr
ambitionen mehr beiträge aber will
keiner
auch von der leyens erfolg hängt am geld
wieder steht die elitetruppe der
bundeswehr ksk unter rechtsextremismus
verdacht ein unteroffizier wurde bereits
suspendiert auch gegen zwei
stabsoffiziere wird ermittelt sie sollen
auf einer privaten feier den hitlergruß
gezeigt haben
verteidigungsministerin kramp
karrenbauer kündigte ein hartes vorgehen
an man untersuche ob es ein netzwerk
gibt deutschlands katholiken machen sich
auf den weg den synodalen weg an seinem
ende soll die wiederherstellung der
glaubwürdigkeit der kirche stehen den
sexuellen missbrauch durch priester will
man schonungslos aufarbeiten und auch um
die rolle der frau und den zölibat wird
es gehen aus münchen linken klingel ein
klares zeichen eine frau zündet die
kerzen für den neuen weg an karin
kortmann vom zentralkomitee der
deutschen katholiken
denn es geht auch um die rolle der frau
und um machtverteilung in der kirche die
debatte zwischen laien und bischöfen ist
in vollem gang
wenn es nicht eine saubere aufarbeitung
mit personellen konsequenzen
strafrechtlichen ergebnissen des
sexuellen missbrauchs gibt dann brauchen
wir auch nicht für einen neuen synodalen
weg zu werden das ist das a und o des
vertrauensverlust geführt
wir streiten uns jetzt schon auch der
zölibat und die sexualmoral der
katholischen kirche sind themen des
synodalen wegs für viele gläubige ist es
längst zeit für veränderungen
weil ich glaube dass das totale weg wir
nur reden reden reden ist das hier ist
jetzt wirklich die letzte chance ich
kann gar nicht verstehen dass einzelne
bischöfe immer noch nicht mitgehen
wollen diesen synodalen weg kardinal
marx sprach in seiner predigt von einem
aufbruch aber natürlich im einklang mit
rom
da stellen wir uns denn vor wir sind in
deutschland die kirche losgelöst und
können einfach irgendetwas entscheiden
ohne dass wir rücksicht nehmen auf alle
anderen das wäre völlig undenkbar
im januar beginnen die gespräche
zwischen bischöfen und gläubigen die
große hoffnung vieler das von
deutschland ein signal ausgeht
traditionell zu beginn der
weihnachtszeit haben die beiden
christlichen kirchen mit feierlichen
gottesdiensten ihre spenden kampagnen
gestartet
die evangelische hilfsorganisation brot
für die welt hat im
schleswig-holsteinischen rendsburg ihrer
aktion begonnen
unter dem motto hunger nach
gerechtigkeit in freiburg feierte das
katholische lateinamerika hilfswerk
adveniat seinen auftakt es ruft unter
dem motto friede mit dir zu spenden auf
zum sport und der schreibt ja manchmal
wunderbare geschichten zum beispiel die
eines ski rennläufers der sein glück
kaum fassen kann
am 30 november 2008 zehn verletzte sich
thomas dreesen schwer am rechten knie
ein jahr und zwei stunden später ist er
wieder da und gewinnt fast sensationell
den abfahrtslauf in lake louise es ist
ein märchen dass thomas dreesen schreibt
1 dass er selbst kaum fassen kann
beim comeback nach einem jahr
verletzungspause gelingt den 26-jährigen
in lake louise kanada 1 perfekt
abfahrts rennen zwei hundertstelsekunden
ist dresden schneller als super g
weltmeister dominik paris
da hängen im netz kinder und bin
verletzte neues und das dessert so
aufgeht
wahnsinn am 30 november 2008 10 stürzt
dresen mit höchstgeschwindigkeit auf der
abfahrt in beaver creek totalschaden im
knie saison-aus für den kids musiker
2018 mit dieser beeindruckenden rückkehr
auf die piste hatte niemand gerechnet
dresden hat in seiner karriere nun
insgesamt drei abfahrtsrennen gewonnen
und ist jetzt der erfolgreichste
deutsche in dieser disziplin in der
fußball-bundesliga hat borussia
mönchengladbach die tabellenführung
zurückerobert durch ein 4 2 gegen den sc
freiburg und der alte und neue
formel-1-weltmeister lewis hamilton
gewinnt souverän das saisonfinale in abu
dhabi in seinem mercedes feiert emmel
und einen ungefährdeten start-ziel-sieg
vor max verstappen und charme na klar
dessen ferrari kollege sebastian vettel
landet nach einer panne beim boxenstopp
nur auf platz fünf das ist auch so ein
endresultat in der gesamtwertung bei nur
einem saisonsieg
nächstes jahr will das natürlich besser
machen danke zum schluss haben wir noch
das wetter für den wochenbeginn
da kann es morgen an den alpen schneien
im norden eher regnen sonst wieder meist
trübes und trockenes wetter bei null bis
acht grad so viel von uns für den moment
wir sagen tschüss mehr um 21.45 von
marietta slomka morgen begrüßt sie
barbara hahlweg an dieser stelle und
hier gehts jetzt gleich mit berlin
direkt und theo koll weiter hallo theo